c'est ici en banlieue de moscou environ
800 personnes ont été incarcérées depuis
les deux dernières semaines 1800 mhz et
au total en russie c'est beaucoup plus
que ça mais il ya tellement de monde à
incarcérer qu'on se sert aujourd'hui de
ce centre de détention qui al'habitude
accueille les immigrants illégaux pour
héberger tous ces jeunes qui sont en
état d'arrestation et là où on est les
familles les amis viennent déposer des
vivres d'abord des nécessaires de l'eau
des draps parce que nous on a rencontré
des jeunes qui venaient juste d'être
libéré et qui ont partagé avec nous des
photos qu'ils ont pu prendre à
l'intérieur de leur cellule ce sont des
conditions assez difficiles dans
certains cas les jeunes sont incarcérés
une nuit ou deux mais ça peut aller
jusqu'à deux semaines donc les gens vous
voyez ici ce sont des membres des
familles qui viennent y attendre et une
fois qu'ils franchissent les portes de
l'établissement peuvent déposer la
nourriture sans avoir la garantie
qu'elle sera acheminé à leurs proches
sont des jeunes qui souvent ont été
appréhendés pendant les manifestations
mais d'autres l'ont été dans la rue
alors qu'il sortait du métro ont eu des
arrestations arbitraires à moscou depuis
quelques jours déjà
donc ils n'ont pas idée pourquoi
exactement ils sont incarcérés ça peut
aller du désordre public ça peut aller à
apple pour violation des mesures
sanitaires pour la commune 19 ou encore
d'avoir incité à la protestation mais
règle générale et de l'aveu même du
kremlin tellement de personnes que le
système carcéral en ce moment n'est pas
capable de traiter tous ces prisonniers
même si des prisonniers temporaire ça
vous donne une idée de l'ampleur des
mesures répressives qui ont été mis de
l'avant par les gouvernants par le
gouvernement russe
depuis les manifestations occasionnés
par le retour de la vanille pour les ter
pour décourager surtout les jeunes de
protester bateau
comment autant c'est répugnant donc les
gens viennent bon espoir de pouvoir fois
parler à leurs trois jetons encore leur
déposer des vivres mais aucune garantie
de caen exactement ils vont pouvoir être
libéré
il cita marc altérer ce que radio-canada
moscou